it was a far cry from eran's last visit
6 years ago back then he and his Greek
counterpart openly argued about the loan
treaty that set the borders between
their countries a century ago this time
he and president Karina sakaru avoided
all controversy the two governments
signed 15 Accords to double their trade
and build a new bridge across their
border and they agreed to disagree about
who will control more Maritime space in
the aan and Eastern Mediterranean which
has brought them to the brink of War
five times in as many
decades GRE and tur need to live
peacefully to express their differences
and discuss them honestly and to
constantly try and find Solutions and if
those differences are unbreachable they
should not automatically lead to
tensions and
crisis we wish to turn the agent into a
sea of PE and cooperation we want to be
an example to the entire world with the
steps Greece and tury shall take
together the fact that Maritime borders
were off the table doesn't mean they
were ignored they'll be discussed in
future this visit was designed to reset
the mood to have two countries less
intentions improve rhetoric agreed to
meet again prime minister motakis it was
said is going to visit anara in this
spring have concrete measures that bring
tourists Turkish tourists with a visa to
Greek Islands again agreement on
refugees and most importantly in many
ways double bilateral trade from 5 to 10
billion euros these are concrete
positive measures but why now erdogan
spent much of last year threatening to
invade Greek Islands mitsakis asked the
US Congress not to sell turkey f-116
that might be used against Greece when a
Turkish frigate attempted to ram a Greek
one in 2020 there was a real fear of
armed conflict for years now turkey has
put pressure on Greece to come to terms
on Maritime borders but two earthquakes
early this year flattened Turkish cities
and created a need for Western
investment in reconstruction and ongoing
Wars in Ukraine and Gaza have already
created great risk for both the Greek
and the Turkish economies so the
appetite for gunboat diplomacy and high
seas confrontation seems to be falling
away there seems to be more appetite for
stability the real test of course is Yet
to Come whether the Greeks and Turks can
indeed come to a bilateral agreement on
Maritime space that has eluded them for
decades and if not whether they can
agree to submit to arbitration at the
international court of justice in the ha
John Saros Al jazer
Athens make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz